[Music]
and mixture holds that humans and
Neanderthals interbred they had sex
anywhere between forty to eighty
thousand years ago they had kids and we
were a much more numerous group than
humans were than the nano-cells we
numbered them ten to one and slowly
gradually over the years their DNA just
whittled away just get grounded away and
we kept some of that but the nano-cells
themselves disappeared because they had
sex with us in other words that's the
reason they're not around today they had
sex with us that's the theory they
should have done that and and so you
know the nano-cells net never really
became extinct they became us okay
that's what they're saying so what's
wrong with it well I mean it's probably
a lot of things wrong with it but what
do you want to talk about in this well
to begin with they did many tests on
mitochondrial DNA which is again part of
the DNA that's transferred from mother
to children okay Kenny could be females
or males it doesn't matter but it's it
comes we it's the mother that bequeaths
it to us right and we have no
Neanderthal mitochondrial DNA we have no
nanda though mother's you only have
human mothers which is predictable
predictable yeah yeah no surprise there
we have no white chromosomes from the
Ender thoughts which means males today
human males have known younger fell
fathers so the only kids that survived
were females that came from Nana though
fathers and human mothers that's
supposedly that's what the theory or
that's what the objective data
today the only way the rationalize all
that is they try to write a whittled
away so that's why it can't be found
nowadays so what they did over time you
know they kept insisting you know they
want to prove a mixture at all cost
you know this has little to do with
science it's got to do a pause it is
trying to explain why than he had it
falls down like this yeah now if the
whole point yeah and so then they
brought the geneticists in or they just
barged in I don't know which of the two
yeah because they wanted that business
they wanted to get into the anomaly a
genetic issue yeah you would think but
then what happened is they did all these
genetic tests they all failed to show
any you know that we had any
mitochondrial DNA so they said oh how
about nuclear DNA nuclear DNA the DNA
contained in the nucleus of the cell
right and so they said why don't we look
at the nucleus itself the nuclear DNA
and they did what is called the genome
the genome is the material that's
contained you know the genetic material
that's continued to sell and and so they
said let's do a genome a complete genome
on an amethyst and they were able to
find three different samples and they
did a genome and the project the article
from this project came out in 2010 and
and both what the article says what the
paper said was what their findings were
that mutant nanos house or humans have
between one and four percent
nan de Velde DNA match no there's one to
four percent of our DNA matches that
Amanda before any human any individual
human nucleus right so so if let take
your DNA and do an analysis we will find
that there's anywhere between one and
four percent of your DNA that matches
that of Nana Thal so these three nano
though they did the genome on ok and and
so from that tiny amount
remember we failed mitochondria we
failed Y chromosome but from this 2%
this 4% later they revised it to 2% but
from this tiny amount they made a
mountain out of a molehill they say ah
we have proven a mixture we have proven
with this that humans and Neanderthals
had sex and kids anywhere between 40 to
80 thousand years ago because look
here's the evidence it doesn't that have
to do with our common ancestor they deny
that possibility they say no it has to
do only with the fact that we had sex
with them again anywhere between 40 and
40 to ten eighty thousand years ago okay
within that time when we had sex we had
kids and we are the kids
we are the offspring okay but we have to
look at what they're studying hypothesis
was what their premise was how did you
know what were their predictions when
they started to do the genome right and
and here you you haven't stated by
Svante Paabo he was the head of the
project and he states this at the Nobel
conference 50 in 2014 and he says the
following
he says if there was a contribution from
Neanderthals to Europeans we would
expect Europeans to share more genetic
variance with Neanderthals than what
Africans do since there has never been
and of those in Africa that's what he
says at the conference a few years
earlier when they published their report
this comes directly from their report to
test whether nanda thoughts are more
closely related to some present-day
humans than to others we identified snps
called
that stands for single nucleotide
polymorphism al Dells
no L is a variant form of a different
gene by comparing one randomly chosen
sequence from each of two present-day
humans and asking at the end of those
mats the alleles of the two individuals
equally often if gene flow between you
and a thousand mother and humans ceased
before differentiation between
present-day human populations began this
is expected to be the case no matter
which present-day humans are compared
under the alternative model later gene
flow between
Annabel's and mother
we expect Neanderthals to match alleles
in individual some from some parts of
the world more often than the others let
me translate that into English now what
it what are they saying here they're
saying if there was no interbreeding if
we get it from 500,000 years ago all
humans today should have approximately
the same amount of DNA if instead if
instead we get it from when we made it
with an amethyst forty to eighty
thousand years ago which was after we
came out of Africa it would be then some
people some people should have more DNA
than others yeah and that's exactly what
they found they found that some people
have more than others but specifically
whom well they found out that Europeans
white people like me right we have more
Neanderthal DNA than Africans okay we
have more data at all
DNA than Africans but something is wrong
with this working hypothesis see because
this prediction it should be that
Africans should have no might occur and
no nuclear DNA whatsoever because
because he's saying you say nein
everyone's everything so they should
have none in fact that's exactly what
the popularization magazines interpreted
they said oh Africans should have none
that's what the study found that's not
what the study time here what the
popularization magazine said here's 2014
LA Times tiny amounts of Nan without DNA
have been found in Europeans and Asian's
but not in sub-saharan Africans whose
ancestors stuck around when they're
cousins left the continent so the same
Africans should have not here's another
one science and tech mail online 2016
indigenous sub-saharan Africans have
been found to have no Navajo DNA as
their ancestors did not follow the same
migration route
here's National Geographic 2016 most
Europeans and Asian's have between one
to two percent Neanderthal DNA
indigenous sub-saharan Africans have
none or very little nanavali a because
ancestors did not migrate through
Eurasia so so these people I mean is
there a difference between none and some
between nothing and very little isn't
that just a question of the migration
routes like who went where no it's got
to it's got to do with the following
if Africans never made contact with
nanda though they should have none and
if and if we later contaminated them
with our nanda they'll DNA then all bets
are off anything goes that anything goes
yeah in other words everything should
have zero none whatsoever DNA because
they never were in contact with
knitathon nanda those were never in
africa yeah
if africans have some and that's what
these guys show only a couple just to
making sure that at that point here is
pablo tedtalks 2011 stir this lee
speaking there is no difference in how
often the nanda thought matches one
african or the other
but this is different if we now look at
the european individual and an african
then significantly more often does a
Neanderthal monster european rather than
the african so he's not saying Africans
have serum that he's saying we have more
that's all he's saying his tribe the
public 2013 anova when we compared one
African to a European individual
Dinanath all match the European
individual more often than the African
no you should expect zero but Europe
yeah but neither Fred yeah and then came
back to Africa ah but they're not saying
that if they came back to Africa then
all bets are off and we don't know how
much anybody should have if everybody
got contaminated but I thought they're
showing that Africans now have less than
the Europeans because they're only
dependent on who came back rather than
who stayed if that's true that
prediction should also follow for the
Asians American Indians and the Papua
New Guineans have more Neanderthal blood
than Europeans the people who came into
humans that keep into Europe and made it
with a Neanderthal they should have more
than anybody else that's what we should
that's not the case the agents have more
than the Europeans the Europeans have
more than uh than the Africans we should
have none and if there is backflow if
the if they came back and they everybody
slept with everybody then we don't know
one that it should be equal or they
should all be equal we lost complete
track of who should have washed so you
can't make a prediction but these people
say we've proven it because we have more
than the applicants what where do the
agents and the American Indians have
more well we don't know that's
interesting
yeah you see what it what they're saying
here he responded Pablo again 2013 in
the genome Canada and the big
contribution from nano those I would
have expected it to be in Europe and
nowhere else
because Neanderthals lived in Europe and
Western Asia but we found it also in
China and even in Papua New Guinea where
everyone assured there had never been a
US and he's right that's what you should
but that's not what they were working
hypothesis was theirs was we can predict
that we have more than the Africans yeah
well we should we can also predict using
that logic that we should have more than
the Asians and that wasn't the case but
they kind of downplay that and they say
oh look we've proven it because we have
more than you have they are wrong with
that means that whatever starting point
is wrong that that their presentation
huh this is how they explain this away
here you have Lopez what is it 2015 that
says using genome-wide data back to
Africa and mixture into the Horn of
Africa was dated to around 3,000 years
ago what is he saying he's saying that
there was there were Europeans who came
back to Africa through the jungles of
Africa 3,000 years ago now if you do
your number 3,000 years ago what is that
the Romans the ancient Greeks the
persons who came back to Africa 3,000
years ago and impregnated the African
ladies in the jungle this is nonsense
these people are saying that the one
reason that Africans have some
Neanderthal DNA is that someone came
back from
and impregnated them and you know gave
the cheese that well they don't mean
reason yeah but then we lost all track
and then how to explain the ancients you
know how does it has it the ancients and
the American Indians ended up with more
but he says here's my de pavo Nobel
conference fifty in 2014 the model we
proposed is to say that when these
modern humans came out of Africa they
presumably passed by the Middle East
these early humans mixed with the
nano-cells and then went on to become
the ancestors of everybody outside of
Africa in other words they're saying
that humans came out of Africa and and
before they got the Europe they
encountered them in Israel and Iraq in
the Middle East and there they they got
together they had a big party they had
sex kids the majority of the flow of the
stream went into Europe and they made it
with a Europe with a Nanda Falls there
but a small trick or what they agent and
somehow that they they think that that
created more never called DNA over there
than in Europe then among it makes no
sense whatever they can't explain it
away in other words they can what they
do is they downplay the Asian part and
they in the you know highlight the
Africa although we have more than yeah
everything about the Asian say yeah more
than then the Europeans explain now
[Music]
Oh God
so what should we do with the
geneticists at the Max Planck Institute
well let me tell you what I think come
on mama
[Music]
you